Hi! This time, we will just go a little bit further than in the previous examples.
When we click on a button, we will force the loading of the track, we will read the content,
add cue listeners in order to trigger events when the video is played and we will display
them on the side this time, and there are hyperlinks you can click and if I click somewhere, the video
starts at the corresponding location and you can see that the cues are highlighted in black
as the video advances. There are not a lot of subtitles at this location
but... you can see that the transcript is highlighted as the video is playing.
What have we added to the previous example? The first thing is that we just defined a
rectangular area here: it is just a div with an id="transcript", and we added some CSS here,
for locating the video and the transcript on the same horizontal position, so that the
video can grow and the transcript too. We use floating positions, I put ‘float:left;’
for the transcript that is on the right because if I put 'right' it will grow but it will
be aligned on the right... and I prefer it on the left.
We can give a look at the CSS, there is nothing complicated and this can scroll because of
the overflow:auto; rule we added to the div. When we click on the buttons here, we call a
function called loadTranscript(), instead of forceLoadTrack(0) and forceLoadTrack(1),
this time we just ask for a particular language and, it's implicit, but we are also looking
for track files that are not chapters. Let's have a look at this loadTranscript() function
here. So the loadTranscript() function has a parameter
that is the language. The first thing we do is that we clear the div,
we are just setting the content to null and then we disable all the tracks: we set the mode
of the all the tracks ‘disabled’ because when we click here and we can change the language
of the transcript, we need to disable all track and enable just the one we are interested
in. How can we locate the right track with the
language? We just iterate on the tracks... this is the
text tracks object... and we get the current track as an HTML element and as a TextTrack
and using the TextTrack, we just check the language and the kind. And if the language
is equal to the one we are looking for, and if the kind is different than chapters, then
this is the track we would like. By forcing the mode to "showing", in case the
track has not already been loaded, it will trigger (it will ask the browser) to load the file.
This is where we test if the file is already been loaded, it is exactly the same test we
did in the previous example. If the track is already loaded, just display
the cues in sync with the video and if the track has not been loaded, display the cues
after the track has been loaded. This is the same function as the getContent
we had, except that we renamed it. This takes the track as an HTML element and
the TextTrack as parameters. Let's have a look at how it is done.
"displayCuesAfterTrackLoaded" just waits for the load event to be triggered and then
it called display the cues function that will display the cues in sync.
Either we call it directly if the track is loaded, or we know that the loading has been
triggered if necessary, and we just wait in the load event listener.
Let's have a look at what displayCues function does.
The displayCues function is exactly the same as the readContent we had earlier.
It gets the cue list for the given track, add listeners to the track. And instead of just
displaying the plain text below the video as we did earlier, we will just make a nice
format and we will add the id of the cue in the element we are creating.
Let's have a look... I'm calling the inspector...  let's have a look at one of the list items here.
You can see that in the list item we use the CSS class called cues, just for the
formatting, for putting them in blue and adding an underline when the mouse is over,
and we use the id of the cue in the list item. So the id is 10, and we also created an onclick
listener that calls the function we will detail later, that is call jumpTo.
And here is the starting time of the cue. What we did is that we created a list item
with a given id and if we click on it, it has a click listener that will call the jumpTo
with the time as the parameter. This is the trick, this onclick listener
that will make the video jump to the right position.
How did we create that? We use classical techniques. So we created a string called clickableTransText
that is just an HTML list item with the id, the onclick listener that is built with the start time
of the cue and we just add this list item to the div.
This function here, addToTranscriptDiv, just adds in the DOM the HTML fragment.
We can give a look at addToTranscriptDiv. It just does transcriptDiv.innerHTML += this text.
The jumpTo method that makes the video jump... in order to jump to a particular time
in the video we are just setting the currentTime property of the video element and we want
it to start playing as soon as the jump is done. So video = document.querySelector("#myVideo") is just the video HTML element.
I recommend to look slowly at the code, it is a bit longer because we added some formatting
for the voices and so on, but it is not complicated. Take your time and look at how it's done....